Salut !
Est-ce que vous saviez
qu'il y a des personnes
qui n'ont pas accès
à leur imaginaire visuel ?
C'est-à-dire qu'ils sont
même pas capables
de se représenter une pomme
dans leur esprit.
On appelle ça de l'Aphantasie.
C'est un terme
qui est beaucoup revenu
dans les commentaires de mes vidéos
où je vous expliquais des techniques
pour mémoriser
des choses facilement.
Ou débloquer une compétence
dans le cerveau.
ça passe souvent
par l'imaginaire visuel,
mais ces personnes là
ne peuvent pas.
Et saviez-vous, qu'il y a d'autres
personnes qui ne sont pas capables
de reconnaître
les gens qu'ils croisent,
le visage du moins,
des gens qu'ils croisent.
Ou leur propre visage,
même parfois.
C'est un autre problème, ils n'arrivent pas
à mémoriser en gros les visages.
On appelle ça de la Prosopagnosie.
Et aussi, est-ce que vous saviez
qu'il y a des personnes
qui sont au contraire,
incapables d'oublier des choses.
Donc ils mémorisent tout,
toute leur vie, tous les détails.
Ils savent pas oublier.
Et ça on appelle ça
de l'hypermnésie.
En bref, trois pathologies vraiment
spéciales liées au cerveau
et en particulier à la mémoire.
Et c'est de ça qu'on va
parler dans cette vidéo.
Monique, générique !
- Loïc, Loïc Générique.
- Depuis quand ?
- Depuis quand quoi ?
- Depuis quand quoi, quoi ?
- De quoi ?
- Depuis quand, quoi, quoi.
Mais heureusement,
pas de problème
ou de troubles de mémoire
pour le nouveau Xiaomi Mi 10T.
Parce que Xiaomi
sponsorise cette vidéo.
Le gros point fort de ce téléphone
qui est déjà ready pour la 5G,
c'est sa compatibilité
avec l'assistant vocal Alexa.
En gros, vous téléchargez
l'application gratuite
Amazon Alexa
sur le Google Play Store.
Vous le configurez ensuite
avec votre compte Amazon.
Et vous pouvez contrôler
toute votre maison,
poser toutes les questions
que vous voulez.
Du style, raconte-moi une blague.
- Monsieur et Madame Neymar
ont un fils.
Comment l'appellent-ils ?
- Moi je dirais Jean.
- Jean, parce que Jean Neymar.
Apparemment, Loïc, le Xiaomi Mi 10T
peut faire des vidéos avec nous.
Il a à peu près le même
humour que nous.
Bon comme toujours chez Xiaomi,
on est sur un rapport
qualité/prix imbattable.
Et je vous donne maintenant les très
bonnes caractéristiques du Mi 10T.
Vous avez à l'arrière, une triple caméra
ultra haute résolution.
La meilleure fluidité
d'écran qu'on ait pu voir
sur un téléphone de chez Xiaomi,
avec un taux de
rafraîchissement de 144 Hertz.
Une très bonne batterie, un très bon
processeur qui est compatible 5G.
Et surtout, il y a plein
de choses créatives
qui sont directement
intégrées au téléphone.
Par exemple, vous pouvez
faire du dual vidéo,
qui permet de filmer les deux côtés
de l'écran en même temps.
Et pour faire des vidéos
un petit peu stylées avec.
Vous pouvez aussi faire
du clonage photo-vidéo.
Vous avez le mode ralenti
même du côté selfie.
Un mode de longue exposition,
c'est pratique quand
il n'y a pas beaucoup de lumière.
Un mode Vlog,
en gros c'est vraiment encore une fois
un très bon rapport qualité prix.
Que ce soit pour le pro
ou dans le quotidien.
C'est-à-dire pour se divertir.
vous avez tous les liens en bas
dans la description.
Du coup, Loïc, je me pose la question,
est-ce que ce nouveau téléphone,
ça va faire comme
ma carte graphique ?
Il va disparaître de mon bureau,
et je vais le retrouver
dans tes mains avec,
"Non mais c'est parce que
je le prends pour..."
- Ah !
- Parce que, ouais.
Je vais essayer
de le garder un petit peu.
Imaginez dans votre esprit
qu'il y a un gros ballon jaune.
Un ballon de baudruche, tout jaune.
Maintenant toujours
dans votre tête,
vous prenez une aiguille
et vous éclatez le ballon.
Et quand il éclate,
derrière vous voyez un clown.
Un très gentil clown,
c'est pas un méchant clown,
qui vous sourit
avec un gros nez rouge.
Okay, est-ce que
vous avez l'image de ça ?
Si vous avez une image
de ça dans votre tête,
même si elle n'est pas parfaite.
Vous n'êtes pas
atteint d'aphantasie.
Par contre,
si vous n'avez pas réussi à imaginer ça
dans votre imaginaire visuel,
eh bien c'est que vous êtes
malheureusement victime d'Aphantasie.
Chaque personne a une imagerie
mentale visuelle qui lui est personnelle.
C'est à dire, on a nos propres images
de pomme, de ballon,
d'aiguille, de clown, etc.
Après dans notre tête
c'est plus ou moins précis.
Mais pour vous dire,
il y en a chez qui c'est tellement précis
dans leur imaginaire visuel.
Qu'ils sont incapables de dire
si l'image qu'ils ont en tête,
c'est quelque chose
qu'ils ont vu dans leur vraie vie
ou qu'ils ont juste imaginé.
A quel point ça ressemble à une photo,
ce qu'ils ont en tête.
Là aussi c'est un cas
extrême plus rare.
Pour les autres, c'est plus
ou moins net dans l'esprit.
Et donc il y a une
catégorie de personnes
où ils ont absolument aucune image,
rien, nada, Nothing.
Il s'agit donc d'une incapacité à
produire une image mentale visuelle.
Il y a quand même 2 %
de la population qui en serait atteint.
C'est quand même assez énorme.
Rien qu'en France,
ça représente presque
un million et demi de personnes
atteints d'Aphantasie.
Un million et demi de personnes.
Et on parle d'eux
quasiment jamais en fait.
Le premier à l'avoir évoqué,
ça serait Francis Galton,
c'est un cousin de Charles Darwin.
Il aurait parlé de ça en 1880.
Mais le monde scientifique moderne,
ne s'est vraiment intéressé
à cette pathologie
que très très très récemment.
En 2010, il y a un neurologue
qui s'appelle Adam Zeman,
il a écrit un article avec des collègues
à lui, neuropsychologues,
dans la revue
Neuropsychologia.
Cet article parle d'un patient.
Patient que nous
appellerons Bernard.
Bernard a 65 ans, il se fait opérer,
comme ça arrive parfois,
d'une artère coronaire
qui est bouchée.
Mais pendant l'opération,
Bernard se plaint
d'une petite sensation
dans sa tête
et dans son bras gauche.
Dans l'article qui est publié,
il est indiqué que Bernard
a fait à ce moment-là,
un très rapide accident
vasculaire cérébral.
Et cet accident,
même très rapide,
n'est pas anodin parce qu'il a entraîné
la dissociation dans son esprit,
enfin dans son cerveau.
De la région cérébrale qui sert
à produire des images mentales,
de la région cérébrale qui sert
à la perception des choses
et des images mentales.
En fait voilà comment
ça se passe dans le cerveau.
On a le cortex visuel, c'est un peu
la page blanche dans notre cerveau,
de quand on veut dessiner mentalement
ou projeter une image mentalement.
C'est un peu le cadre
du rétroprojecteur.
Tu vois Loïc ?
Si tu vois mentalement,
c'est plutôt bon signe.
ça, ça joue le rôle de page blanche.
Et le cortex préfrontal
vient dessiner directement dessus.
Chez Bernard, les deux sont déliés
donc il est incapable
de projeter une image.
Et lui, qui était à la base
géomètre retraité.
A été habitué tout
au long de sa vie,
à faire appel à son imagerie
mentale visuelle.
Là où ça devient fou,
c'est que même ses rêves
sont devenus aveugles maintenant.
Donc il a des perceptions
visuelles quand même,
des couleurs,
des choses comme ça.
Il a des sons.
Mais il n'a plus d'image,
on a coupé l'image.
Là où ça devient
encore plus intéressant,
c'est que suite à la publication
d'un article à propos de ce cas,
dans une revue de vulgarisation
scientifique américaine.
Il y a une vingtaine de personnes
qui contactent la revue,
parce qu'ils se disent un peu pareil,
ils se reconnaissent dedans,
ils se disent aphantasiques.
Ce sont majoritairement
des hommes d'ailleurs.
Sauf qu'à la différence de Bernard,
eux déclarent qu'ils sont atteints de ça
depuis leur naissance.
Et c'est pour ça que ça leur
paraissait complètement normal.
Leurs coordonnées sont
envoyées aux scientifiques.
Scientifiques qui avaient déjà eux,
contacté d'autres personnes
aussi de leur côté.
Les scientifiques préparent
un questionnaire qui leur envoient,
ainsi que le VVIQ.
Tu connais le VVIQ Loïc ?
- C'est pas Vicks Vaporub ?
- Non c'est pas...
Putain j'étais tellement sûr
que t'allais partir là dessus.
- C'est les chips !
- Non, le VVIQ.
- Comme John ?
Le VVIQ, c'est un questionnaire
qui a été développé en 1973
par un psychologue qui s'appelle
David Francis Marks.
Et c'est un outil de travail pour voir
les différences de niveaux
dans la perception de l'imagerie
mentale, entre les individus.
C'est donc grâce aux données qui ont
été recueillies par ces questionnaires,
que les neuroscientifiques
ont pu décrire ce trouble,
qui est vraiment particulier.
Les personnes qui sont
atteintes de ce trouble,
s'en aperçoivent en général
à l'adolescence.
Lors d'une conversation
par exemple,
où on parle d'un programme télé
ou quelque chose comme ça.
Et puis quelqu'un qui rappelle
une scène visuellement et toi tu dis :
Je vois pas ça,
toi tu vois ça dans ta tête ?
Oui et pas toi ?
Et là ils se rendent compte
qu'il y a un souci.
Et c'est arrivé aussi que
des personnes s'en rendent compte
en regardant une vidéo YouTube.
C'est le cas d'un jeune homme
qui s'appelle Thomas.
Thomas regarde une vidéo
d'une chaîne YouTube de Pit.
C'est la chaîne
"Apprendre à dessiner".
Et sur cette chaîne là,
Pit apprend aux viewers
à dessiner sans aucun modèle.
Donc il y a Pit
qui dit dans la vidéo,
je vous mettrai
le lien dans la description.
Pit dit, imaginez un cube bleu
dans votre esprit.
C'est bon tout le monde
voit le cube dans sa tête.
Et là thomas se dit,
Bah non pas moi.
Du coup il se dit, mais là
il y a peut-être un problème.
Parce que si tout le monde doit
avoir ça en tête et que moi je l'ai pas.
Comment ça se fait ?
Du coup Thomas envoie
un message à Pit,
de la chaîne "Apprendre à dessiner.
Pit lui répond et lui propose
de faire une vidéo ensemble.
C'est celle-ci que je vous mettrai
en lien dans la description.
Où il se fait un entretien d'à peu près
une heure avec Thomas,
où ils parlent, du coup
de l'Aphantasie.
La découverte de son trouble, etc.
C'est juste passionnant,
si vous avez une petite heure
devant vous, regardez la.
Et pour ceux qui se poseraient
la question, la vidéo est en français.
D'ailleurs Thomas explique,
que comme il a pas d'image mentale
pour réaliser une tâche
que nous on visualiserait.
Avant de la faire, il utilise
beaucoup sa voix mentale
pour certaines choses
qu'il doit faire par étapes.
Par exemple,
il se donne toutes les étapes
en se les disant à l'intérieur mentalement.
C'est comme une espèce
de check list,
pour aller au bout
de ce qu'il entreprend.
Et c'est intéressant,
parce que ça veut dire que son
imagerie mentale auditive elle,
elle fonctionne très bien.
Et donc il a compensé avec.
D'ailleurs ce qui serait génial,
c'est que les instituteurs
ou les professeurs
en début d'année scolaire,
ils puissent tester un petit peu
tous les élèves sur l'imagerie
mentale cérébrale.
Pour voir quels élèves
ont plus de mal
avec la sollicitation
d'une imagerie mentale.
Ou voir avec quels élèves,
il n'y a pas d'imagerie mentale du tout.
Ce qui permettrait du coup,
d'adapter les cours
pour cette personne là
ou la manière de faire, etc.
Je sais que toute manière,
d'année en année,
les profs, les instituteurs mettent
pleins de choses en place.
Que ce soit pour la mémoire ou
les différents troubles et ça c'est cool.
Mais ça, ça pourrait être
encore une étape en plus.
Parce que du coup,
on pourrait solliciter
autre chose comme
l'imagerie auditive mentale.
Au final pour le moment,
on ne sait pas vraiment comment aider
les personnes qui disposent
d'une mauvaise imagerie mentale.
On sait seulement que
le stress et la distraction
ne sont pas des bons effets
sur la qualité des images.
Donc le calme et la concentration
pourraient aider à obtenir des résultats.
Par contre ce qui est tout
aussi fascinant, c'est donc l'inverse.
Je vous en parlais
au début de la vidéo,
c'est des personnes qui présentent
des signes d'hyperphantasie.
Donc ils peuvent
décrire des images
qui sont tellement
précises dans leur tête,
qu'ils ont du mal à savoir,
si c'est une image
qui a été vue dans la vraie vie.
Ou si c'est juste une image
qu'ils ont imaginée dans leur tête.
Alors même si Thomas
n'est pas capable
de s'imaginer
le visage de ses parents.
Quand ils sont devant lui,
devant ses yeux
il sait les reconnaître.
Et ça c'est donc pas
le cas des personnes
qui sont atteintes du trouble suivant,
la prosopagnosie.
Si Loïc se mettait à ma place
et démarrait la vidéo.
Les personnes qui sont atteintes
de prosopagnosie,
ils y verraient que du feu.
Ils s'en rendraient pas compte
ou presque pas compte.
Le mot prosopagnosie,
ça vient du grec Prosopon
qui veut dire visage.
Et Agnosis qui veut dire ignorance.
C'est un déficit de
la reconnaissance des visages.
Donc parents, amis, amoureux,
Matt Pokora, tu reconnais plus personne.
- Sa daronne, c'est Matt Pokora ?
- Ouais.
Aucun de ces visages n'est ancré
dans la mémoire d'un prosopagnosique.
Pour certains,
même leur propre visage leur sont
inconnu et ont du mal à s'ancrer.
Alors si des problèmes de
reconnaissance de visages
étaient déjà connus.
Le terme de prosopagnosie,
lui a été utilisé pour
la première fois en 1947
par un psychiatre Allemand,
Joachim Bodamer.
Il a utilisé ce terme pour qualifier
ses patients qui présentaient
des difficultés à
reconnaître des visages.
La prosopagnosie aujourd'hui,
on sait ce que c'est.
On sait que c'est lié à une lésion
dans l'hémisphère droit,
sur le dessous du lobe temporal.
Et peut-être dû à un AVC,
une tumeur, un traumatisme crânien.
Mais elle peut aussi être
présente depuis la naissance.
Et peut alors être
en partie dû à l'hérédité.
Il existe même des familles
de prosopagnosiques.
ça ne doit pas être hyper simple
pour s'offrir les cadeaux à Noël.
- Tiens Didier, c'est ton cadeau.
- Non mais moi c'est Martine,
Didier est là bas.
- Bah non Papa,
Didier c'est moi.
Pas simple.
Comme pour l'Aphantasie,
il est probable que vous connaissiez
un prosopagnosique dans
votre entourage, sans le savoir.
Il y a environ 2 % de la population,
qui serait prosopagnosique
depuis toujours.
Avec une gravité après
plus ou moins variable.
Soit encore une fois, presque un million
et demi de personnes en France.
Et souvent, les prosopagnosiques
ignorent que les autres
ne sont pas vraiment comme eux.
C'est le cas d'ailleurs
pour une comédienne,
que vous connaissez peut-être.
Qui s'appelle Aude Gogny-Goubert.
Vous l'avez vu sur pleins de chaînes
d'ailleurs comme Golden moustache
ou dans son propre format
qui s'appelle Virago.
Moi, c'est une pote à moi.
Et un jour,
j'avais détecté ça chez elle.
Du coup elle s'était
fait diagnostiquer.
Et elle est vraiment prosopagnosique,
elle ne le savait pas.
Elle en a parlé sur la chaîne
de "Dans Ton Corps".
C'est pareil, c'est passionnant.
Et son témoignage
et des explications.
Je vous mets le lien dans
la description, si tout va bien.
C'est important aussi de préciser,
que la plupart des sujets atteints
savent lire les émotions sur
les visages qu'ils regardent.
Ils ont pas de mal
à décrypter une émotion.
Ils n'ont aucun souci
à voir les visages
en tant que tels quand
ils sont devant leurs yeux.
Mais leur cerveau est
incapable de les associer,
par contre à la bonne personne.
Il y a des histoires
assez fascinantes,
comme un homme qui a dû
abandonner le service militaire
parce qu'il n'arrivait pas à
dissocier aucun de ses collègues.
Tout le monde a la même tenue,
tout le monde a la même coupe
de cheveux, la même démarche.
Donc lui, c'est un cauchemar pour lui.
Laurent Cohen, c'est un professeur
de neurologie à l'hôpital
de la Pitié salpêtrière.
Il expliquait que
l'un de ses patients,
avait été victime d'un accident
vasculaire pendant la nuit.
Le patient dormait.
L'accident donc du coup est passé
inaperçu ou presque inaperçu.
Parce que le lendemain matin,
quand il s'est réveillé
il a eu un sursaut devant
le miroir de sa salle de bain,
en voyant un inconnu.
Il ne s'est pas reconnu lui-même
dans le miroir de la salle de bain.
Il n'a pas reconnu non plus
le visage de sa femme
quand il est retourné
dans sa chambre.
Mais il a reconnu
le collier qu'elle portait.
Et il s'est dit,
je connais cette voix.
Et c'est avec ce genre
d'astuces d'ailleurs,
que les prosopagnosiques
fonctionnent au quotidien,
surtout ceux qui
le sont de naissance.
Ils ont des petits tips en fait,
ils s'accrochent à des choses.
Il y a d'autres personnalités aussi,
que vous connaissez
qui sont conscients
de leur prosopagnosie.
Il y a Thierry Lhermitte
ou encore Brad Pitt
qui a avoué que certaines personnes
pensaient qu'il était très égoïste
et très prétentieux.
Parce qu'il leur parlait pas
quand il les croisait.
Alors qu'en fait, c'est simplement
qu'il les reconnaît pas.
Mais comme je vous disais,
heureusement les personnes
atteintes de ce trouble peuvent s'aider
de pleins d'éléments pour reconnaître
les personnes de leur entourage.
Donc ça peut être les bijoux,
les vêtements,
le style vestimentaire, la voix.
Y compris la démarche d'ailleurs,
qui peuvent être d'excellents indices.
Je me dis même qu'en ce moment
avec nos masques H24,
ils doivent limite être avantagés
pour reconnaître les gens
autrement que par leurs visages.
Moi, je galère un peu.
Il y a des fois dans des situations,
les gens que je vois pas souvent
pour du taf ou des trucs comme ça,
j'ai du mal à les reconnaître.
Mais parce que tout
est basé sur le visage.
Pour les prosopagnosiques en fait,
comme le visage de base
ça leur sert pas.
Peut-être avec la démarche
et la coupe de cheveux,
c'est un peu plus
simple pour eux, j'imagine.
Là aussi, il existe l'opposé
de la prosopagnosie
qui peut se trouver
chez les super-physionomistes.
C'est des personnes qui peuvent
reconnaître dans une foule un visage,
qu'ils ont croisé des années
auparavant juste cinq minutes.
C'est le cas de l'écrivaine française
Amélie Nothomb
qui reconnaît tous ses lecteurs.
Et qui les appelle par leur prénom,
chaque fois qu'ils viennent
la voir en dédicace.
C'est pas une légende, c'est vrai
et c'est hallucinant de la voir faire ça.
Bref, la prochaine fois
qu'une personne que vous connaissez
ne vous reconnait pas dans la rue,
ne partez pas du principe
que celle-ci ne vous aime pas
ou qu'elle est hautaine.
Elle vous a peut-être pas reconnu,
elle a peut-être tout simplement
d'une manière plus ou moins forte,
une forme de prosopagnosie
Ou elle n'a pas envie de vous parler,
mais ça c'est autre chose.
Loïc, est-ce que tu peux me dire,
ce que tu as mangé le soir
du 18 décembre 2009 s'il te plaît ?
- Des ravioles.
- T'es sûr de toi ?
- Non.
- Que tu saches pas ça,
c'est normal.
Par contre un hyperménsique
lui, il en serait capable.
Il serait même capable de
se remémorer chaque jour de sa vie,
jusqu'à un certain moment
de son enfance.
Après il y a une sorte de mur.
L'hypermnésie,
qu'on appelle aussi
la mémoire autobiographique
hautement supérieure.
La MAHS.
C'est donc la particularité d'avoir une
mémoire autobiographique détaillée,
mais style à l'extrême.
En fait, l'hypermnésie,
ça permet pas de retenir
forcément l'ensemble de sa vie.
Mais ça permet souvent
de retenir un tas de détails
et de choses insignifiantes.
Les personnes
qui en sont atteintes
n'ont pas moyen d'intervenir dans
les éléments qu'ils mémorisent.
Ils peuvent pas décider que ça,
ils vont le mémoriser
pour toujours et ça pas du tout.
C'est pas de leur fait.
En général la majorité est conservée
dans leur tête qu'il le veuille ou non.
L'hypermnésie est vraiment différente
de notre mémoire à nous tous,
qui fonctionne souvent
sous forme de flash.
On a des flashs mémoriels,
on n'a pas toujours l'avant ou l'après.
C'est également
différent d'mnémoniste,
qui comme moi
je le fais parfois d'ailleurs,
va utiliser des techniques de mémoire
pour retenir des choses qu'il a choisies.
Comme des décimales
de Pi par exemple.
Un exemple au hasard.
Mais en fait en gros,
je les ai pas lues juste une fois.
J'ai passé beaucoup de temps.
Beaucoup, beaucoup trop de temps,
même peut-être pour mémoriser ça.
La première personne qu'on connaît qui
présente un syndrome d'hypermnésie
ou qui ressemble à de l'hypermnésie,
même si on l'appelle pas
comme ça encore à l'époque.
C'est un journaliste Russe.
Il s'appelle Salomon Cherechevski.
Enfin, il s'appelait d'ailleurs,
parce qu'il a vécu de 1986...
De 1886 à 1958.
Et lui, il avait une mémoire
incroyable qui était basée
sur une table de rappel,
qui était innée chez lui.
Si vous connaissez pas, en gros
on associe des chiffres à des images.
Et lui il avait ça
depuis la naissance.
Donc c'est l'inverse de moi,
puisque pour moi une table de rappel
c'est quelque chose
que j'ai construit, que j'ai appris.
Et je sais pourquoi telle image
est liée à tel chiffre.
Lui, il s'est rendu compte
de sa particularité
au cours d'une réunion matinale
avec son rédacteur en chef,
les autres journalistes
avec qui il travaillait.
En gros il y avait le rédac 'chef,
qui donnait toutes
les instructions de la journée.
Tout le monde notaient
tout ce qu'il y avait à noter.
Et lui ne notait rien,
du coup le rédacteur en chef :
"Bah Salomon, vous n'écoutez rien,
vous notez rien.
Est-ce que vous êtes capable
de me dire ce que j'ai dit ?".
Il a été capable de ressortir
tout ce qu'il a dit,
que ce soit à lui,
aux autres en général.
Et même un petit peu avant.
Et c'est peut-être pas normal en fait,
que je retienne tout ça comme ça.
Donc il s'avérait qu'il était synesthète,
c'est ça la synesthésie.
C'est être synesthète.
Et qu'il était probablement doté
d'une mémoire quasi absolue.
Mais le premier cas qui a reçu
le diagnostic d'hypermnésie,
c'est celui de Jill Price.
C'est une américaine née en 1965.
En 2000, Jill contacte un chercheur
à l'université de Californie.
Et elle lui explique
qu'elle se souvient normalement
ou anormalement de son enfance.
Mais que les jours qui suivent
la date du 5 février 1980,
sont tous imprimés
dans sa mémoire.
Mais en mode heure par heure.
Et là on se dit, mais en fait c'est stylé,
j'aimerais bien savoir faire ça.
Mais c'est pas cool en fait à vivre.
Jill en l'occurrence,
elle le vit comme un vrai fardeau.
Qu'elle lise une date
sur une page d'un journal
ou qu'elle entende une autre date
au cours d'une conversation.
Et il y a tous les souvenirs de sa vie
de cette période là qui font surface,
avec la même intensité émotionnelle
que le jour de l'événement en question.
Elle a pas le choix,
ça arrive un peu comme un torrent.
Et elle est obligée de repenser
à tout ça, dans les détails,
donc c'est hyper crevant.
Le chercheur James Gaugh,
a dédié ensuite
les cinq années qui suivent 2000,
à étudier le cas de Jill.
Il a fait d'innombrables
tests sur elle.
Et elle se souvient bien
de tous les jours de sa vie,
à partir du 5 février 1980.
Il avait son journal intime
d'adolescente, qu'elle avait pas relu.
Qu'il avait pour chercher ça, des témoignages
de pleins de gens autour d'elle.
Tout ce qu'elle disait
était correct à chaque fois.
La chose qui est
encore plus surprenante.
Elle se souvient
de tous les événements
qui se sont passés dans le monde,
auxquels elle a manifesté
un tout petit peu d'intérêt.
Encore une fois, tout ça
après le 5 février 1980.
Avant c'est normal.
Pour l'anecdote, les chercheurs
se sont procurés un livre
dans lequel sont recensés la plupart
des événements historiques
récents de l'histoire américaine.
Ils ont donné tous
les événements à Jill,
et lui donnaient de donner la date
à laquelle correspondait l'événement.
Jill durant ce test,
a fait une seule erreur.
Sur tout le bouquin,
qu'une seule erreur.
Et cette erreur là,
il s'est avéré après vérification,
que c'est le livre qui se trompait
et que c'était pas Jill.
Donc en fait, elle a fait 100 %
de bonnes réponses.
Elle a été capable de dire,
le livre il se trompe là.
Autre truc de ouf,
si vous montrez 50 mots à Jill,
elle est capable de
les reconnaître par la suite.
Mélangés à d'autres mots
dans un texte immense.
Mais si vous lui demandez
de les réciter,
elle sera moins forte que
la moyenne pour faire ça.
Donc elle dit d'ailleurs qu'elle,
perdre ses clés c'est très courant.
Elle se note des choses
qu'elle aurait peur d'oublier.
Donc c'est pas non plus,
elle absorbe pas tout comme elle veut.
Et elle récupère pas les informations
comme elle veut en fait.
Les travaux de ces chercheurs
ont en tout cas permis
de mettre en lumière
des nouveaux cas incroyables.
Comme celui de Rebecca Sharrock.
C'est une Australienne, elle a
aujourd'hui une trentaine d'années.
Et elle affirme
que son premier souvenir,
remonte à la période où elle était
encore dans le ventre de sa mère.
Mais elle se souvient en tout cas
en détail de son premier anniversaire,
de la peluche Winnie l'Ourson
qu'on lui a offert, mais qui l'effrayait.
Elle est également capable de réciter
mot pour mot, sans aucune erreur.
Chacun des livres d'Harry Potter.
Il y a des cas d'hypermnésie qui sont
parfois nommés hyperthymésie.
C'est une forme d'hypermnésie,
qui se caractérise par le fait
que des personnes qui ont ça,
se plaignent de ne pas
pouvoir oublier leurs souvenirs.
Et ça c'est une vraie
grosse pathologie,
parce que c'est dur de voir
revenir des souvenirs.
Les bons comme les mauvais,
sans pouvoir contrôler
le flux dans leur tête.
C'est un nombre de cas qui est
vraiment très très rare dans le monde.
C'est sûrement un des troubles
les plus durs de la mémoire,
d'être dans l'incapacité
d'oublier quoi que ce soit.
Vous aussi d'ailleurs,
vous pourriez oublier quelque chose
de basique, mais de très important.
C'est de vous abonner
à cette chaîne YouTube,
en activant la cloche,
il faut faire les deux.
Ne vous inquiétez pas, c'est gratuit.
Moi je m'appelle toujours
Fabien Olicard.
Si vous avez aimé la vidéo,
pensez à la liker.
Si vous pensez connaître
des gens prosopagnosiques
ou que vous l'êtes vous même,
ou Aphantasique.
Parlez-en dans les commentaires,
je serai ravi d'avoir votre témoignage
et qu'on puisse lire un petit peu ça.
Ici, moi je vous mets deux vidéos.
Une sur le fait de débloquer
une compétence dans votre cerveau.
Et sur une capacité d'agent secret.
On a fait un test d'agent secret,
qui est basé justement sur la mémoire.
Donc vous pouvez
regarder les deux.
Moi je vous dis à très bientôt,
Ciao !